because every single day of this year
has been yet another page torn directly
from a george orwell novel you can't
believe it's real
but unfortunately it is some democrats
are now calling for a
truth and reconciliation commission
to try or assess trump supporters after
the election truth and reconciliation
commission
this weekend for example former obama
adviser robert reich was a labor
secretary under bill clinton
wrote that truth and reconciliation
commissions would quote name
every official politician executive and
media mogul whose greed and cowardice
enabled this catastrophe
end quote several msnbc anchors have
made the same suggestion chris hayes for
example
in july another msnbc personality
offered a preview
of these commissions let me take an
example like the
truth and reconciliation commission in
south africa because a good example
because apartheid went on for a long
time but
basically people would come before that
commission and admit it was a truth
telling they would say i
did this and that was the birth of the
concept of
reconciliation because they were able to
admit what they did wrong here in
america we have a different problem
in that there are a whole bunch of
people say i didn't cause this problem
might have been my ancestors or maybe
i'm a recent immigrant it's somebody
else's
fault how do we convince people that it
doesn't have to be their fault
to be their responsibility to fix it
south africa is the model seriously
that's not a rhetorical point by the way
or a demagogic one do you know anyone
who lives there of any color
how's that country going now seriously
that's their model okay jd vance is the
author of the book hillbilly elegy we're
always happy to have him
on the show jd great to see you so it's
it's strikes me that one of the many
ironies here is that
a lot of people maybe a lot of higher
income
voters want to want the chaos to end
they want something calmer
so and they want they do want like
actual reconciliation which is good
and so they're voting for biden in the
hope of that his supporters calling for
a truth and reconciliation
commission doesn't sound like a first
step toward reconciliation to me
uh no it doesn't tucker and this really
is like you said
torn from a page out of a george orwell
novel because you know it's
there's you know who can protest truth
or reconciliation
uh but a truth and reconciliation
commission would not be about truth and
it wouldn't be about reconciliation it
would be about revenge
and what i find just so preposterous
about this idea setting aside the fact
that it's it's just a terrible idea
is that it's incredibly whiny right i
mean these guys lost an election in
2016.
they're unhappy about it okay i get it i
wouldn't like losing an election either
but instead of trying to win the next
election and moving on with
the life of american democratic politics
they want to go backwards and punish
everybody
and i i just can't help but think why
are you guys being total babies and
talking about this
the election is in two weeks focus on
that and not on punishing the people who
voted the way that you didn't like
we've never done anything like that in
this country i mean
reconstruction was very tough on the
losers obviously
but we've never had a former president
indicted for example we just don't
behave that way in this country and i
wonder if saying things like this isn't
tampering with the formula
of america i think it definitely is and
what worries me most about this
tucker isn't what it means about those
who
worked in the trump administration uh
those who maybe can't find jobs now that
they're looking for jobs in the private
sector
i see it more as a warning for the
future whether it's a second trump
administration
or a republican president who comes
after really what this
is saying is you're going to be punished
for trying to implement your ideals and
principles and
into the work of government as you know
well you can't actually run a government
with just one guy a president is
obviously the most important piece
but you need people running the cabinet
departments you need people working at
the white house
and if the warning that's out there is
we're going to come after you
if you work in the administration of
somebody who holds your values
then it's going to be harder to actually
staff a republican government
governance that's right in the future so
i i really think that this is a really
dark threat that's going to cast a real
paul over
a lot of american politics for the next
few weeks and hopefully
not after that but of course we know
when you open pandora's box it just
keeps going
yeah i think it's a really smart point
that you just made it's scaring the hell
out of people
in the meantime and that has its own
cost i would say jd vance great to see
you
thank you